passe maintenant au second débat de sens
public vous savez on fait le choix de
chaque soir de nous décaler
volontairement de l'actualité de prendre
du recul et ce soir c'est un droit de
suite que nous vous proposons quinze
jours après la publication du rapport
sauvé qui révéler l'ampleur systémique
des violences sexuelles dans l'église
catholique faut-il réformer
l'institution jusqu'où comment réparer
les évêques doivent t'ils démissionner
avant de répondre à toutes ces questions
avant d'en débattre sandra cerqueira
revient sur les conséquences de rapport
de la commission
330 mille victimes de violence ou
agression sexuelle en 70 ans dans
l'église française des chiffres
accablants qui ne peuvent en aucun cas
rester sans suite selon le président de
la commission sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église jean marc sauvé il faut que
l'église catholique sans par deux à la
fois nos analyses l'état des lieux des
propositions et qu'elle prenne les
mesures qui s'imposent depuis les appels
à réformer l'église se multiplient
le rapport sauvé avant certaines pistes
pour combattre ces violences notamment
la levée du secret de la confession
mais pour le président de la conférence
des évêques il faudrait trouver un autre
moyen pour venir en aide aux victimes
jusqu'à confession s'impose à nous et
ils s'appuyaient les plus forts salaires
publics et en sachant cela est plus fort
que la république maintenant il faut que
nous voyons pour parce que il ouvre un
espace de parole libre qui se fait
devant dieu
des propos qui ont provoqué un tollé
jugée inacceptable par le ministre de
l'intérieur à l'origine d'une loi contre
le séparatisme
il a rappelé que la loi de la république
s'impose aux églises parmi les autres
propositions au coeur du rapport sauvé
se trouve aussi la transformation de la
gouvernance de l'église invités à
s'interroger sur la concentration de
tous les pouvoirs aux mains de l'évêque
de sacrements et de gouvernement le
manque de contrôle interne et la faible
place des laïcs et des femmes dans les
lieux de décisions on voit bien que
l'arrêt des réformes on se ferme et
difficilement et on voit bien que là
encore l'aspect théologique qui est très
important alors que là il faudra battre
à baisser par rapport à pau à la société
est il des humains donc ça va être très
long les évêques et les religions ont
déjà lancé un certain nombre de
chantiers sur la question de
l'indemnisation financière un fonds de 5
millions d'euros a été créé
comment réformer l'église voilà le thème
de notre débat je vous présente mes
invités christine pedotti bonsoir à tous
bienvenue vous êtes directrice rédaction
et la publication de la revue témoignage
chrétien
le père françois lebon soir soit venu
vous êtes père jésuite théologien
rédacteur en chef de la revue études
jean françois colossimo bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous historien des religions
directeur des éditions du cerf hauteur
avec régis debray et didier leschi de
république ou barbare lui voilà j'aurai
je voulais évidemment citer votre livre
matthieu croissandeau est resté à mes
côtés et christine pedotti commencé avec
vous après les conclusions de la
commission sauvé le 11 octobre dernier
avec d'autres vous aviez appelé à la
démission collective des éveils devrait
démarrer avec ça pour quoi
alors d'abord parce que d'une certaine
façon c'est un peu une évidence c'est à
dire que on arrive devant pas seulement
des défaillances mais vraiment une
faillite dans ces cas là je dirai dans
la vie ordinaire les dirigeants d'un
ensemble d'une société d'un autre état
qui se retrouve dans cette situation là
bas ils présentent leur démission ils
disent pas seulement qu'ils ont honte ce
qu'ont dit les évêques et puis la
deuxième raison c'est que en régime
catholiques qui se trouve que je suis
catholique il ya une vraie solidarité
des évêques entre collectivement et avec
leurs prédécesseurs donc même au sens de
ce qu'on appelle l'ecclésiologie
catholique il y à une logique à ce que
collectivement ils répondent de cette de
cet état de fait puisqu'ils sont les
responsables c'est timo logique les
responsables répondent et la réponse qui
est à la hauteur de la catastrophe
c'est cette démission d'autant qu'il ya
des précédents les évêques du chili ont
démissionné dans les mains du plus un
père le cardinal archevêque de munich
reinhard marx a posé sa démission lui
aussi en disant que qu'en fait c'était
une façon de dire qu'il était
complètement qui prenait en charge cette
affaire là depuis réfléchissant je me
dis que d'une certaine façon joseph
ratzinger le pape benoît 16 a aussi
démissionné devant la même catastrophe
qui touche l église donc ça ne me semble
pas si absurde que ça jean françois
colosimo ce jeu de marc parent ça parce
que c'est peut-être
été abordé rapidement jusqu'à la faire
du chili est un peu différente du chili
s'est pas françois qui se sont tout à
fait piéger par une conférence
épiscopale laquelle aucun des membres
assez important qui protège un prêtre
retenu réputé au chili pour sa
pédophilie le pape mal informés un ne
prend pas totalement sa défense b 10 ou
12 ans et ça finalement devant la presse
ça provoque un tollé à le cardinal
archevêque de boston qui est
particulièrement présent sur ces
questions
de pédophilie le conseil je crois bien
le pas franchement expliquant qu'il faut
réagir et une direction c'est que le
pape demande donc là c'est le président
de la holding oui houphouet a demandé
aux directeurs des filiales
hongroises démissionner on a bien bossé
[Musique]
les actionnaires le monde de missionner
c'est à dire qu'il est des machines
enfin d'accord l'aspect hiérarchie de
l'église envers
m parce qu'il considère que les flouer
d'accord mais est ce qui va lui
permettre de réintégrer au plus tôt de
désintégrer au delà de se ferait sur la
chimie au delà de ce focus sur le cinéma
revenant sur
wii non mais c'est important parce que
c'est pas ton cas le deuxième point
c'est que de toute façon c'est bien la
conférence des évêques de france qui a
commandé c'est vrai de toute commission
qui l'a financé à hauteur de 3 millions
peut-être qu'elle l'a fait de manière
contrainte sous le positionnement mais
elle l'a fait voyez est généralement bon
alors moi je sais pas je suis chef
d'entreprise et milan édition que quand
on commence dano dit je sais pas
généralement pour démissionner à la fin
c'est pour réformer vu l'ampleur des
révélations il fallait il faut aller
jusque là très sincèrement je pense que
cet homme femme je comprends tout à fait
les raisons de mon amie christine
pedotti je pense que ça vaut rien
ajouter parce qu'ils auraient été
installées il n'y a pas de tant de
candidats à l'épiscopat je pense que en
plus oui bien sûr il peut y avoir des
questions de responsabilité collective
voire transhistorique mais dans ce cas
précis on est face à un corps épiscopal
qui à travers son président en tout cas
a accepté de mener une commission qui
nous a laissés soigner et librement et
qu'ils ont de très nombreux points parce
qu'elle est française est exemplaire
avec un concours des sciences humaines
qui serait certainement inimaginable
ailleurs et avec le fait que au fond
c'est antony tu que c'est pas forcément
la réponse
porter un nom puisque voilà
je le demande à titre symbolique c'est à
dire que je ne dis pas faux flanqué tous
les évêques de l'est du mali en dehors
des archives et
leur pose beaucoup de sang mais si ça a
beaucoup de sens ça a beaucoup de sens
de dire comme me reihnhart mart marx le
cardinal archevêque de munich le pape a
restauré en lui disant bah oui mais
recommencer c'est une façon de mettre
aussi les choses un peu à zéro parce que
je veux dire on est un peu catholicisme
année zéro l'un dans dans la situation
dans laquelle on est donc c'est une
façon de dire on va recommencer à
réfléchir ensemble
voilà c'est je pense que ça va dans le
catholicisme on aime les grands axes la
liturgie les symboles et c'est donc moi
je demande qu'on pose un symbole facto
françoise
cette commission est l'ami quand même en
lumière le caractère systémique de ces
de ces violences sexuelles jusqu'aux
appartements on a un caractère
systémique ça suppose une réponse
collégiale effectivement c'est un
symbole oui j'aime paraît alors bon un
jour je reste sur cette première phase
comprend je comprends bien là la demande
de christine et la dimension symbolique
effectivement de la chose est encore une
fois l'exemple du cardinal mars il
trouvé très intéressant de poser un
geste fort pas simplement bon le pardon
demandé la honte est très bien mais
comment manifester symboliquement à
lorsque c'est une démission bon il me
sens collective je suis un peu plus
hésitant il rejoindrait les positions de
dans un conditionnement là dessus mais
en tout cas il faut quelque chose ou on
verra ce qui se passe à lourdes mais en
tout cas on va se contenter simplement
de dire on va s'en occuper
et france est très important aussi que
les actionnaires
donnent de la voix c'est à dire qu on
est tellement habitué à cette dichotomie
entre
uniski par elvis qui écoute ma vieille
formule il enseignants utilisent
enseigné
que on a besoin d'une prise de parole
de ce qu'on appelle les laïcs en faction
en fait les baptisés sont en fait qu'ils
soient qui constitue une église qui
prennent la parole alors ils vont
l'apprendre peut-être de manière un peu
parfois un peu forte au début mais bon
mais pourquoi pas il faut de temps en
temps mais les pieds dans le plat pour
que les choses avancent oui d'ailleurs
je vais en wallon va d'une certaine
façon la zone est là tant il ya eu pas
mal de réactions sur les médias sociaux
notamment twitter avec erwan le morhedec
qui a lancé un beau diez un hashtag
aussi mon église on va citer plusieurs
plusieurs tweets vous les lisez en même
temps que moi je cite un passage d'erwan
laïque nous réclamons les réformes
nécessaires pas au rabais pas au minimum
avec ambition pauline qui dit tous
responsables de notre église tous
responsables de la réforme et on va en
citer un autre anne-cécile ne pas nous
laisser confisquer notre parole et
participez vraiment au changement la
demande de réforme elle s'exprime
fortement là on est quinze jours après
on a pris un peu de temps de deux reculs
permet vous la sentez s'exprimer 700
demandes de réformes oui je le trouve
effectivement de réseaux sociaux dans
les conversations qu'on peut avoir bon
il ya des attentes très fortes
certainement
après ça ailleurs la difficulté dans
l'église ces gauchos dépendent de la
hiérarchie c'est à dire plein d'idées
comme ça tu vas dire à la base mais
ensuite pour que ça se fera pas sans les
fêtes il faut qu'il y ait un signal
mais en même temps ça peut pas je sais
pas on verra tout est ouvert pour
l'instant je ne suis pas forcément ni
pessimiste ni optimiste
j'entends aussi la part de certains
évêques des réactions assez forte je
pense à jean paul vi co2 dorrans que des
prises de position assez forte
vous pouvez nous rappeler ce qu'il a dit
a alors là vous
disent qu'ils veulent qu'il faut
réformer de façon radicale ce que je
sais ce que je vais faire ma team et de
son propos mais en tout cas nécessité
d'une vraie réforme fondamentale la
formule de luc ravel en dix ans
l'archevêque de strasbourg 10 ans xi a
pas de réforme on va finir comme une
secte
donc c'est vraiment gentiment quand on
est au pied du mur mais j'ai d'ailleurs
c'est le thème d'une éternelle que vous
avez publié demain dans témoignage
chrétien vous vous dites catholicisme
année zéro mort telle religion c'est à
dire vous pensez qu'on en est à 7 à ce
niveau dans je
sais c'est que je dis un paul valéry dit
les civilisations sont mortelles l'a
peut-être que la forme religieuse
catholique est en danger mortel c'est
peut-être ça parce que j'ai à ce qui se
passe en france à l'on peut dire le
catalyst est universel mais dans tous
les pays où les commissions de ce type
ont eu lieu on a trouvé les mêmes
résultats il ya encore des grands pays
catholique qui n'ont pas fait la lumière
en pologne un certain nombre de choses
oui mais je n'ai que le portugal
l'espagne l'italie rien rien en asie
rien en afrique et je le dis dans mon
éditorial en afrique on a une sorte
d'accumulation parce qu'on a à la fois
les problèmes qui sont liés aux églises
locales et puis en plus qu'il est
probable qu'on a exfiltré les pays
européens ont exfiltré des prédateurs en
afrique donc vous imaginez moi je reçois
aujourd'hui des messages qui arrivent
d'afrique je sais d'ailleurs pas quoi en
faire de gens qui me disent qu'ils ont
été agressés
sur 20 par les réseaux sociaux et est
aujourd'hui j'ai rien j'ai pas de siège
au lait ou les adresser est l'un des
problèmes c'est que aujourd'hui il ya
une extériorité je dire on sort de
l'église la chose la plus simple c'est
de s'en aller c'est de ne plus en être
de l'église catholique d'où la phrase du
mont saint aignan ravel en disant qu'il
existe peut devenir une secte jean
françois colosimo l'église elle c'est
pas elle va se réformer on peut
l'imaginer l'espérer moi je l'espère en
tant qu' en tant que catholique mais
mais c'est pas nouveau et s'est
plusieurs fois réformer oui j'ai eu
église catholique sa définition main n'a
cessé de se réformer bien avant
l'apparition la réforme parce que le
génie romain le génie de rome c'est très
précisément d'avoir suggéré
correspond à des grands moments a des
airs de l'humanité en refondant son tout
en restant intangible surnom d'homme je
dis moi mais en étant capable d'adopter
des formes d'expression pour penser
évidemment regardé la succession dans
l'ordre esthétique de la nes par le lien
qu est-ce que c'est l'art catholique
mais il ya autant d'art catholique et
une art dans les années 2000 ans donc et
c'est vrai aussi pour la pensée est plus
élevée des conflits qui sont très forts
d'un prévu dès qu'on sorte de la
théologie fondamentale par regarder sur
la question sociale via une doctrine
sociale de l'église enfin il ya aussi
des gens qui sont reposés vous pouvez
trouver théologien libéraux comme vous
pouvez trouver des théologiens
solidariste enfin donc j'ai faut pas
sous-estimer s'est alors pas sic et
historien des religions à sion français
qu'on en est à un point de rupture on va
le dire
écrit comparaison n'est pas raison est
évident on a eu des crises marquée par
de très forts des hommes moreau qui se
sont traduits par des réformes phares de
la réforme grégorienne ouais on a eu
aussi un peu plus tard une crise autour
du rose 12e xiième siècle a sorti l'an
mil et peur apocalyptique des dérives
sectaires
voilà ce qu'on voit c'est que dans
l'église catholique ça s'est traduit
toujours
précise que je suis pas catholique ne
suis pas en train de faire imploser pour
nos moules pour l'église catholique
ce qu'on voit c'est que en fait à chaque
fois ça a suscité un mouvement spirituel
particulier penser à cluny n'est ce pas
penser aux ormonts dian les dominicains
les franciliens pensent et léo jésuites
à après la réforme à chaque fois il ya
eu une espèce de sursaut qui a été
justement une manière d'euros date les
cartes toujours les mêmes cartes lrba de
joueurs différents pour affronter le
moment we hope le perreux et là la
réponse des jésuites quand même savoir
si cette énergie existe encore et c'est
dans la station en question mais la
réponse des jésuites piano aura le
relatif iconoclaste protestant de tous
les temps pouces avec les protestants
les images c'est pas trop leur truc
la réponse de jésus c'est le baroque
jeudi
via la rose failli de la rose a en tout
cas sur 2010 soit il ya eu des
tournantes ressource bon se redresse et
spirituellement tout en trois une
nouvelle manière d'adresser le message
au monde sans faire varier le message
mathieu va chauffer d'un point de vue
politique
si on considère que c'est un événement
politique la réaction de l'église n'a
pas été assez à la hauteur le rapport
sauvé c'est un choc épouvantable pour
les croyants et c'est un choc
épouvantable pour la société et commence
faut reconnaître à la conférence des
évêques de france d'avoir commandé ce
rapport ne l'avoir finances et d'avoir
permis à la commission sauvé de
travailler en toute indépendance ce qui
est aussi nouveau et c'est vrai de
s'être adjoint toute une série d' aide
extérieure au monde de l'église qui
l'ont fait mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait depuis qu'est ce qu'on a entendu un
pataquès de communication épouvantable
avec cette histoire de basculer wall la
république ce s'applique à au secret de
la confession au sort les confessions
est au dessus donc le grand public a
retenu sa et d'une certaine façon on a
l'impression que l'église constate un
mal endémique est libre en est désolé ça
se passe chez nous mais n'a pas compris
le caractère systémique pourtant
démontré mais le rapport sauvé et le
caractère systémique il a pris des
appels des réformes profondes qui seront
pas en trois jours né en deux semaines
mais au moins dix ans lance tel ou tel
ou tel chantier de réflexion et puis
l'appel des symboles parce que dieu sait
si j'ose dire que la religion c'est une
affaire de symbole et on ne peut pas
avoir une déflagration pareil et
derrière
voilà j'ai honte je suis désolé et puis
[Musique]
il ya une réponse qui est prévu alors là
on parlait déjà dans le débat précédent
du temps médiatique comparée au temps
judiciaire si on parle du temps
religieux il est encore plus long mais
mais mais malheureusement enfin
heureusement les évêques de france sont
dans l'époque et effectivement il va
falloir une réponse qui est intéressant
c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'église c'est qui
bon alors spontanément aller glisser les
évêques belges avec un problème mais
l'église c'est pas que les évêques
précisément et crois que c'est ça qui
est important aujourd'hui qui est en
train de 2,2 de changer de basculer
enfin on va voir
laissons n'est pas n'est pas écrite mais
que justement d'autres prennent la
parole se met en avant et alors il faut
une fois il faut que ce soit validé par
en haut mais on voit ce qui se passe à
lourdes il peut très bien appliqué
l'assemblée des évêques début novembre
et vous voyez le temps le temps jusqu'à
début novembre pour une réponse oui mais
construit des évêques
comment dire le concile vatican ii est
un moment très important bon il a été
attendu très longtemps le fait des
décennies que les gens attendaient qu'il
guillot ce qui se passe bon ça fait et
est en fait beaucoup je n'attendais rien
dû concilier il s'est passé un événement
quand même assez majeur tout peut
arriver à dire moi je ne je ne bloque
pas antérieurement les choses je
regrette effectivement encore une fois
comme je fais d'accord avec avec vous
qu'il n'y ait pas eu de parole un peu
forte qui étaient manifestés plutôt bon
mais des choses peuvent se passer
peuvent émerger c'est bon ça peut bouger
de manière intéresse alors je voudrais
qu'on est sur du jeu le grand chef c'est
à dire le fameux françois reprendre vos
termes de tout à l'heure 6 octobre
évidemment au vatican et et on est au
lendemain de la remise du rapport sauvé
il invite les catholiques français
assumer leurs responsabilités
j'exprime le prêtre de france ma
proximité et mon soutien paternel devant
cette épreuve qu'est dolla qui est dur
mais salutaire éviter 14 chiffres entre
sierre et j'invite les catholiques
français à assumer leurs responsabilités
pour garantir que l'église soit une
maison sur pour tous photo t christine
pedotti cas sont les je mets des
guillemets les armes du pape françois
dans dans sa volonté de réformer
l'église je sais pas je vais dire la
nomination des évêques sans doute un
levier évident il y en a il y en a
certainement d'autres oui on sait on
voit bien que c'est compliqué parce
qu'on a
l'élection du pape françois a soulevé
dans des espérances on était en 2013 et
la phrase d'un pape que j'aime bien
qu'est jean xxiii qui disait toujours
moi ici vous savez je ne suis que le
pape je trouve s'applique tragiquement
aussi au pontificat de françois on voit
bien qu'il veut changer les choses mais
que c'est extrêmement difficile
cc c'est un super tanker l'église se
manipule pas ça se manipule pas comme ça
et en plus je pense que son équipage ne
veut pas le faire le boulot c'est-à-dire
sa cure issa d'administration est
extrêmement résistante parce que la
curie romaine soit jamais oubliée
elle est là depuis 800 ans et elle sert
la papauté à les papes
c'est ça mérite d'être rappelée donc la
chose n'est pas facile c'est bien
pourquoi d'ailleurs qu'en 2018 pas de
françois s'adressait au peuple de dieux
et héros catholique en leur disant la
catastrophe et là il faut prendre les
choses en main c'est à partir de cet
appel là qu'il ya eu un certain nombre
de choses qui se sont passées et le
rapport sauvé en france mais la sphère
n'est pas terminé on entame je crains
qu'on ait pour des décennies et pendant
ce temps là la parole de l'église la
parole de l'évangile la parole de la
fois la parole de la fraternité la fable
parole de la tension plus fragiles cette
parole là elle sonne dans le vide où
elle sonne faux et c'est ça et en fait
nous avons deux urgence les victimes et
qui nous devons tous dit nous parce que
là en l'occurrence l'église c'est bien
nous nous leur devons tous la tension la
réparation etc et puis nous avons une
autre obligation qui est de faire le
boulot pour lequel l'église existe qui
est de faire entendre une parole de
fraternité une parole une parole que ce
monde à bien vous entendre quand même
aussi mémé réformer c'est risqué on peut
aussi dire ça donc si un risque de
schisme
si le père prend le pas françois pousse
sa volonté de réforme j'ai joué que
christine pedotti d'une part je voudrais
dire d'abord que le premier grand
fascicule sur lutter contre la
pédophilie est fait par la conférence
des évêques de france en 2002 donc je
suis con peut estimer par exemple par
rapport aux enfants inscrits au
catéchisme ce qu'on déduit je suis
heureux de dire de l'édition des
catéchismes c'est que d'ores et déjà il
ya à peu près une 25% enfants qui sont
plus inscrits au catéchisme par rapport
aux moyennes constatées annuel depuis
vingt ans et que ça c'est une saillie
les infections il ya quelques années
déjà ce qui veut dire qu en fait
contrairement à ce qu'on semble dire les
catholiques qui sont des catholiques
convaincus et fidèle etc ont déjà
beaucoup à absorber de ce choc même si
évidemment l'amplitude des chiffres n'a
pu qu'aggraver est donc en fait que les
catholiques qui était en quelque sorte
un certain présidera et enfants singes
parle sont déjà partis ça faut bien se
rendre compte il faut pas surestimer
donc ça s'est échauffé ça c'est sûr
l'algérie durant rapport sagor parce que
il y avait déjà de toutes ces questions
qui dure depuis une des sessions
l'affaiblissement mais je repose ma
question sur le risque de la réforme
réside aussi parfaitement raison il ya
sept kuryk et une telle structure qui
est un peu le problème que rencontrent
les présidents de la république et des
ministres toi avec l'administration
l'énarchie
les présidents passent les ministres
passent encore plus vite et puis rien ne
change pas ce que les administrations
dix noms ou bloc mais il ya plus que ça
sous le quotidien de françois il ya une
lutte il ya une véritable lutte entre la
manière dont le pas françois veut
aborder au fond la mission la
programmation l'évangile c'est à dire
aller chercher les gens là où ils sont
et avant de leur donner des leçons de
leurs de les écouter pour savoir ce
qu'ils ont à dire n'est ce pas et ça ça
se manifeste par exemple sur les
questions de l'homosexualité
sur les questions du mariage ou est bon
et là on voit très bien que le peuple à
une opposition c'est quand même un tap
qui a affaire avec des cardinaux qui
sont peut-être pas des cardinaux les
plus importants de la rue été mis sur la
touche et tout mais qui écrivent des
tribunes de protestation contre le pape
c'est dans tout ça c'est amusant parce
qu'il se veut ultra conservateurs ont
fait se comporte très gentiment comme
les soixante huitards c'est à dire il en
europe et me font de l'asile propres
contre le pape mais où est ce qu'on a vu
ça n'est ce pas et donc là dessus ça
veut dire qu'il ya un véritable combat
entre une frange on va reprendre des
termes un peu politique c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça parce que l'église
c'est pas le plus compliqué en une
frange conservatrice qui considère que
le maintien d'une partie d'un doctrine
qui concerne surtout les moeurs et fait
quasiment encore avec le dogme et
l'autre partie qui considère que la
question du salut ais première mais dans
l'appareil d'état passé de 100 appareils
d'être à françois il est ultra
minoritaire au vatican
france avait mon père je reste bien
savoir ce que ce que vous espérez des
mois qu'ils qui s'ouvre en terme de
fonctionnement de votre église par les
hiérarchies ont parlé voilà un peu en
plaisantant à depuis lomé structure
pyramidale
je pense une mise à plat de ce ces
éléments là alors ça oblige à passer les
bras que la france évidemment mais au
moins une réflexion qui d'ailleurs
existe un dans le dans le champ
théologique qui existent mais qui est
international et dans les tiroirs parce
que justement tout était bloqué dans
une réflexion sur la gouvernance de
l'église sur les ministères voient
qu'ils se fassent vraiment et qu'il se
fasse avec la participation de tous un
élément que je voudrais rajouter par
rapport à ce que dit seul existe à
l'heure il ya quand même une figure n'en
a pas encore parlé qui est celle de la
présidente des religieux religieuses
france parce qu'il n'ya pas que il n'ya
pas que les évêques n'entend que
religieux je défends aussi la vie
religieuse qui est apparu alors là le
portrait de véronique par grands dans le
monde comme les figures compassionnelle
de l'église je trouve été très juste
c'est à dire une figure qui donne une
durée une autre image alors discrète eu
bon c'est vrai que c'est pas et que sur
une femme n'est pas non plus par hasard
donc j'attends ce que j'attends
effectivement c'est ça c'est que des
figures comme ça comme christine pedotti
à sa façon avec son style mais que peu
apprécié aussi
interviennent adieu à temps et à
contretemps pour justement bousculer la
l'institution et il ya des ressources il
ya des ressources de réflexion n'est pas
seulement d'engagement mais aussi de
penser dans dans des laïcs ou des
religieux qui j'espère vont se
manifester
vous m'offrez une transition sur la
lafam des la place des femmes dans dans
l'église christine pedotti est ce que
est ce que vous pensez assister un jour
à une messe catholique célébrée par une
femme
c'est une question très indiscret sur
mon agent fait
se pose pour nous tous oui mais un côté
ma grand mère étant morte presque
centenaire ça nous donne une petite
chance cette assistance
j'ai en fait je ne sais pas parce que je
pense que vraiment aujourd'hui la figure
du prêtre est problématique si il se
prend pour dieu pour le dire est que ce
soit un homme ou une femme changera pas
substantiellement les choses
c'est à dire que si c'est pour faire en
sorte que les femmes se comporte comme
trop de prêtres le font aujourd'hui
c'est pas la peine donc il me semble
qu'il faut changer la vision des prêtres
de leur place au milieu des autres
qui reviennent et pasteurs qui
deviennent des chefs de communautés qui
soit réellement au service etc c'est je
dis souvent un prêtre catholique il aya
quatre choses c'est toujours un homme
toujours célibataire toujours à plein
temps et toujours pour toute la vie on
pourrait faire varier les quatre
critères que ce soit pas toujours un
homme qui ne soit pas toujours
célibataire que ce ne soit pas toujours
pour toute la vie et que ce soit pas
forcément à plein temps et à ce moment
là on ouvre incroyablement le chant dès
cet instant là les femmes légitimement
pourrait faire le job jean françois
colosimo très sincèrement non je crois
pas que l'on nous le verrons notre
vivant mais va par contre 7 la pilule
l'immortalité et encore non je pense que
c'est bien d'autres questions avant
comme le dit très bien que crée cette
mélodie parce qu'il s'agit de créer
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes sur le
pouvoir mais la question du pouvoir
reste inchangé ce sera pas vers un
véritable progrès parce que c'est pas ça
la question de la question c'est très
précisément comment est ce que on peut
sortir d'une augmentation d'un prêtre en
cas de censure humain qui une sorte
d'avatar du christ parmi les êtres
humains et qui vit parce qu'il a reçu
une grasse tellement particulière il ya
une distorsion complète une déconnexion
complète entre la valeur personnelle et
ils exercice à vis des sacrements qui
sont valides par eux mêmes en vain que
120 et tout ça explique peut-être
certaines formes de schizophrénie dans
le comportement de schizoïdie n'est ce
pas donc là il ya une réforme à faire
cette surévaluation du prêtre elle vient
un moment d'affrontement avec la avec la
réforme c'est à ce moment là que ça sort
beaucoup quand même pour répondre
effectivement à l'espèce du 1 pour le
coup hyper humanisation du pasteur
protestant n'est ce pas qui lui
effectivement c'est pas tout la vie
permet d'ailleurs peut être enfin c'est
plus facile à potasser par la fin du
célibat ce que vous décrivez plus
notamment mènerait le play trouve dans
la virée d'une certaine façon vous voyez
l'église catholique elle connaît parce
qu'elle a des églises orientales
l'ordination des hommes mariés je
précise qu'il n'est pas l'ordination des
prêtres parce que quelqu'un qui serait
prêt de célibataires ne serait pas
autorisée je dirais faire de la paroisse
fonterra de drague ce sera un mélange
abominable du genre mais c'est ça le la
raison disciplinaire mais met donc déjà
posons la question effectivement d'une
inscription
du sacerdoce de la prêtrise dans en fait
une communauté au sein duquel le prêtre
vit au centre probablement parce qu'il a
des responsabilités
et puis il avait une ordination il s'est
vite la liste des sacrements mais il ne
vit pas en dehors de cette communauté il
peut pas vivre sans elle c'est ça l'idée
c'est de remettre le prêt contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait croire c'est de
remettre le prêtre au coeur de l'église
comme effectivement quelqu'un de choisi
pour ab mystère qui a ministère de
service et non pas de mystère de pouvoir
tout ça ça paraît simple de langage
théologique mais en clair il faut en
fait redonnez déjà un sens à la prêtrise
masculine je dirais sa première urgence
qui ne soit pas en fait quelqu'un qui
dise qui peut se dire par exemple chez
elle et veut le dire comme ça qu'il
puisse dire ceci est mon corps en
pensant que c'est quasiment magique
parce que là je crois que c'est là où on
a eu une grosse intersection entre des
problèmes spirituels drame des problèmes
psychologiques graves et une déviation
du son ce
merveilleux aussi la notion de solitude
dans le célibat des prêtres oui et c'est
quand même alors c'est un des poids qui
pèse sur sur vos épaules d'une certaine
façon est ce que le sql vous en pensez
quoi vous là la fin du célibat des
prêtres alors il ya deux
éléments à distinguer il ya la question
effectivement du célibat des prêtres
diocésains d'aguesseau des religieux qui
sont en communauté et qui font le choix
du célibat parce que ça c'est assez
cohérent avec une vie communautaire le
choix du célibat personnel il n'y a pas
du reste que tant existe qu on le fait à
tout à fait sa valeur des
salines et évidemment c'est une question
de choix face années et ça n'est valable
que si c'est une fille et que si c'est
un choix personnel sauf que là c'est une
langue liés sur une essence de cause si
on veut devenir prêtre il faut rester
célibataire mais voilà non mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord que les propos
précédents c'est une question qui est à
qui est à reprendre j'irai encore plus
loin c'est à dire se rappeler qu'au
premier temps d'église il y avait une
diversité de ministère
dont certains étaient occupés par des
femmes que le statut que la notion
prêtre au sens de sakhri me direz
sacrificateur est venu qu'ils ont au
cours du 2ème ou 3ème siècle cgm
troisième siècle bombe un aparté
d'affaires historique
l'intérêt de retrouver justement ces
diversités le ministère ce qui n'empêche
pas qu'il peut y avoir effectivement me
sert de président de communauté f1 doit
ensuite tout ça c'est à repenser les
historiens ne le font les théologiens le
fait aussi est distinguée aussi ce qui
relève justement de l'animation de
communautés de la vie religieuse
communautaire ou et un mythique c'est
moi qui l'aurai clos différentes j'ai
juste une chose parce que si la réponse
au rapport sauvé c'est de mettre un
terme au célibat des prêtres je pense
que ça se tout le monde se goure dans
les grandes largeurs will quand même
dire que le célibat n'engendre pas de la
pédophilie est quelqu'un de la famille
religieuse ils ont tendance des prix
d'un criminel qui gère ça n'est pas le
célibat des prêtres
après que l'église revisite son discours
sa doctrine sur les moeurs oui trois
fois oui sa vision des mots sexualité sa
vision du divorce sa vision de la
sexualité ça sans doute mais il ya aussi
des réformes systémiques abonnés
notamment sur les pouvoirs de l'emec la
fonction de l'emec et quand même juge
partie directeur de conscience
spirituelle pas démesurée
est liée à la question du pouvoir en
fait c'est je pense que tous nous
n'avons pas été assez explicite cette
question de célibat nous en parlons
surtout comme une question pouvoir dire
d'un pouvoir qui est exclusivement
masculin qui ne répondent qu'à l'évêque
lequel ne répond qu'au pape voilà le
prêt qui est en figure de dieu lui même
alter christus et 6 essieux soit les
lignes jésus lui même enfin ça c'est un
truc ya aucune régulation du pouvoir
aucun contre-pouvoir dans une paroisse
le curé il est maître à bord il faut que
l'évêque selon le droit canonique c'est
pas si simple que ça arrête les choses
quand un évêque fait n'importe quoi j'ai
à dire personne peut le virer sauf à
remonter au pape et c'est rarissime faut
vraiment faire des choses monstrueuses
pour que le pape donc en fait le pouvoir
n'est pas du tout régulé et
effectivement la séparation des pouvoirs
n'existe pas donc en fait notre
réflexion sur le célibat n'est pas du
tout de faire une équivalence en disant
c'est parce qu'ils sont c'est aux
matières qui sont frustrés et qui
s'attaque aux morts
en revanche parce que la question était
d'abord posé sur la question des femmes
il ya aujourd'hui on n'en serait pas
suffisamment partout dans la société
pour savoir que le masculinisme c'est la
société hyper masculiniser est en soi un
problème
il ya quelque chose là dedans dans
l'exercice du pouvoir dans une
domination masculine je dirais voilà qui
qui pose effectivement les problèmes
francs n'y a pas de femmes dans le
système que celui pour baisser le voilà
alors c'est le patriarcat chez lui
puisque dieu lui même et perd en il
contient ce problème de la constitution
d'une caste séparer des gens que cette
caste est censé servir c'est ça le
voulait est un problème et donc petit à
petit la constitution au fait d'un
univers parallèle qui concentre tous les
pouvoirs mais qui ne tirent même plus sa
légitimité de la de contre pouvoirs qui
pourraient authentifié l'exercice du
poids c'est ça qui nous passionne
faisait parfaitement raison plutôt fait
célibataires ne pas de pédophile et où
lausanne on l'a bien dit dans a parlé du
secret de la confession mais très
rapidement j'aurais quand même vous
entendre sur cette question perpère
vcomment consigner le secret perfection
et la protection des enfants
c'est la question c'est la question
c'est aussi l'occasion de réfléchir sur
la braise secret dans nos sociétés ce
qu'on a besoin d'une société de
transparence de surveillance et on a
besoin de lieux de secret alors aussi on
a besoin évidemment de protéger le ce
qui est en jeu c'est pas j'allais dire
de protéger le criminel bon que qu'une
personne qui a fait une faute puis se
confier à quelqu'un essayait soulager sa
conscience très bien et qu'on ne répète
pas mais ce qui est en jeu ce sont les
enfants qui sont menacés donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait et physiquement je ne sais
pas ce que je ferai dans ces cas là
j'avais je vais pas arriver
mais demain si pour l'instant je sais
pas ce que je ferais si si je comprends
qu'effectivement la vie enfin la vie au
sens psychologique c'est d'un enfant est
menacée par la personne qui vient me
trouver problème c'est que le dénoncer
si je sais pas comment il s'appelle et
si il part tout de suite c'est un peu
difficile mais
pour moi je sais pas j'ai pas la réponse
il n'y a pas de réponse d'autant plus
que comme ça que vous rappelez le secret
de confession ça secret de profession en
france comme pour les avocats et comme
pour les médecins donc en fait la loi
punirait dans l'état actuel de la loi
faisant la loi punirait le prêtre qui
trahirait à ce créneau confession parce
qu'il aurait rompu un contrat qui est un
contrat de confiance attention c'est à
dire sauf pour les pédophiles
ça n'est pas défini par la loi j'en suis
désolée la loi crée une obligation à
tout le monde de rêver des abus mais la
loi dans son alinéa législateur
d'apercevoir mais elle permet aux gens
de se délier de leur secret
professionnel dans des échappées
dans certains cas et les cas ne sont pas
le législateur l'a mal fait son boulot
parce qu'il ya une contradiction dans la
loi française et s'est pas d'abord dieu
c'est la république il est vrai que la
question que gray se pose mais un anneau
oui mais la vérité c'est que il y à
aussi si vous voulez la question
pour le pas françois la demande et à
rome le secrétariat d'état qui
correspond exactement à dit non c'est
pas possible parce que ça va créer des
problèmes politiques avec les états
totalitaires si on a franchi allez on
termine là dessus mais c'est ça aussi
il faut malheureusement clore ce débat
qui était passionnant merci à tous
d'avoir participé fin de cette émission
je vous donne rendez vous demain